I took a break from going to the gym
yeah because I was so busy I was like
I'm not gonna over exert myself and then
also go to the gym and try to squeeze it
in and then be even more tired and
agitated yeah and now I'm back in the
Rhythm and man the first couple of times
are like
it's unnerving I hate it so much you
feel like a broken robot yeah I always
feel like lumbering and nothing works
right and all the other robots are
staring at you and you just want to kill
everybody I hate it so much I hate I
hate I hate it I hate it and I don't
like the gym well no I just don't I
don't believe the only people that like
the gym yeah have made it their
lifestyle yeah if it's your lifestyle I
get those guys you know like dude wake
up protein shake grind this that but for
normal adults uh Arnold Schwarzenegger
is on Instagram I always go to the gym
it's just part of my life and I love to
go it just feels so good and I get the
Pomp and I feel good and I'm like yeah
Mr Olympia likes the gym yeah yeah yeah
surprise surprise